[Music]
language is one of the fundamental
dynamics in the composition of a culture
the power of a nation is directly
proportional to the power and richness
of its language and thought
a perfect command of language and the
ability to engage
easily in dialogue with others protect a
person from
outside influence language is an
important tool for humankind
in our efforts to better understand the
cosmos and events
both holistically and analytically from
every aspect
language plays a defining role in the
formation of our culture
language is not only a means of speech
and thought
it is a bridge with the significant
function of bringing the wealth of the
past
to our day and conveying today's
heritage and our new compositions to the
future
all of the cognitive intellectual and
scientific reserves
and riches of a nation can become
eternal only by means of a language
powerful enough to embrace this heritage
as a whole
a heritage that has descended from the
ancestors
and taken new forms in the hands of
today's generations
the more richly and colorfully a nation
can speak
the more they can think the more they
can think
the broader is the span their speech can
reach
every single society leaves behind what
they speak and think today for its
validity to be probed
tested and protected by future
generations in this way
a huge reserve of experience and
learning are saved from being wasted
what was right or wrong in the past is
compared with the rights and wrongs of
today so that we do not treat the same
path and suffer
from the same errors this is valid for
all nations of the world
the capacity of a language to express a
thought is related to the level of
development
it has achieved and a thought can become
the instrument by which the language is
tuned
to this level of development if a
language has not developed
with its inner dynamics to voice the
needs of all times
and therefore the users of that language
cannot find the words
corresponding to certain concepts then
that language is deprived of the
supportive thought
and its users are doomed to failure
in a time of industrialization global
commerce
and technological warehouses no one
should stay within the limited span of
dictionaries in hand
or what they hear and learn from the
people around them
otherwise they will have to remain
silent and merely listen to what others
have to say
such difference to the requirements of
the modern age leads to disqualification
from participation in contemporary
societies
the earnings of yesterday should be
conserved as a cultural heritage
and utilized today historical and social
dynamics are threats
with which national ideas should be
interlaced
by all means this should be realized
while opening up to tomorrow and
embracing the modern age
as a matter of fact yesterday has passed
with all
its frame of reference what is more
reaching out to the future at full speed
requires much more sustenance than we
can draw from our homes
family and immediate environment though
they may suffice for a practical daily
needs
[Music]
failure is the inescapable end of the
ill-fated and forlorn ones
who are far from facing their era with
their own language and thought
just as important as ensuring language
and thoughts survive is making them a
property of the masses
societies which do not think and speak
will find
others speak and think on their behalf
logic is in disposal of the tongue in
crowds where there is speech without
thought
those unfortunate ones who cannot put
what they think into words
are slaves of their incapability
although not in great numbers there are
still self-confident thinkers who can
elaborate their thoughts
nevertheless they too are not free from
problems
in many countries those who look like
the elite
from the outside are in truth alien to
their own society
the majority in their society respond to
this elite
with an inner opposition for they do not
trust them
and their thoughts are perceived as
nothing more than mere fantasy and
imported views
you find the pros of these intellectuals
written in their own language but
with the mindset of an alien and when
they have to speak they feel the need to
switch to the
vernacular of their fellow countrymen
thus they're traveling between several
worlds in their inner presence
in a state of multiple belongings to
different realms
at the same time they cannot adjust
their hearts to beat in tune with the
heart of their society
nor can they reflect the pattern of
eloquence
and power of expression embedded in
their language
it would be naive to expect some sort of
valuable service from such people
who are entrapped in contradictions
within their personal world of thought
for language truly to become the medium
of communication
the overwhelming majority of society
must be able to express themselves in it
with full command and reflecting its
true nature
expressions in a complicated way like
loading the real intention
to diverse illusions or signs and
relaying
every subject in the form of detailed
interpretations are obviously not the
most agreeable types of presentation
language is a phenomenon the worth of
which lies intrinsically
in itself like other sciences and
perhaps its importance
is even of a greater magnitude thus
any society should conceive of its
language as a field of knowledge
and the interest of the masses must be
drawn to it
as a pleasurable topic this is possible
only by way of a long list of tasks to
do with language
a successful compilation of every single
word
a careful study of manuscripts a deep
analysis of the methodology and
stylistics
of derivative forms in harmony with the
peculiar nature of a language
to make widely known and used those
words and idioms that have been in use
over many centuries
firmly settled with all their nuances
and with their specific meanings
revealed best in that language
it is of a paramount importance for a
nation to be respectful towards all
these components of
preserving a language if all these can
be achieved
then a language can stand on its own
principles and rules
as rich soft and amiable as a language
can be
a language can become the lingua franca
of an
age while maintaining its inherent logic
it will be in use delightfully and will
be transferred from one generation to
the next
although this expectation does not seem
theoretically or logically exaggerated
it is not easy to realize it there will
be challenges while putting it into
practice
something being logical might not always
mean the same thing as the logic of its
development
transformation and maturation the
unfolding of events
may follow a different path in the case
of constant change the logic of
development must be given priority
above absolute logic the rains
controlling it
must be loosed a little and space from
maneuver must be enlarged
if not language and thought both living
phenomena
will become stagnant as solidified as
rock
and will lose their soul language has a
determining influence on the national
thought
and worldview and their logical
intellectual structure
language has to be in its prime to go
beyond historical
value and respond positively to every
favorable development
nations that can manage to develop their
language and make it
accommodating while at the same time
staying faithful to the roots of it
are the most communicative societies
that are
also most dynamic in thought the
relationship between language and
thought
comprises cognitive and intellectual
reflections on existence and events
transforming these reflections into
sources of information
and becoming productive while forming
links between the cosmos and our
knowledge
the future prospects of a nation are
very much dependent
on evaluating these relationships
we should not cast everything that is
old into oblivion
nor turn our face to the past and close
our doors to what is new
let us embrace the past with the outmost
sincerity
and at the same time salute the coming
days with their open
new developments and transformations let
us not cause any conflict between
language and thought
between our past that is filled with
exalted memories
and our future that we strive so hard
for let us not sacrifice
one for the other the roots that make up
the national spirit should be determined
with the help of research
while relying firmly on those roads a
society
should endeavor to go beyond them our
hearts should be
connected to our essential dynamics of
our spiritual heritage
and our eyes should be fixed beyond the
horizon
we should aim to live and flourish with
an insatiable
thing for opening out this is how it can
be possible
to make future generations survive
[Music]
those generations to whose sake we
should bind our existence
it must be those selfless men and women
who are devoted to making
other lives and expect nothing in return
who cherish this life best
with its all possible dimensions
you